[Musica]
benvenuti nel nuovo episodio del leccio
con karim usa è finalmente siamo tornati
anche in questo 2018 e parto subito col
dire che io questo video non lo volevo
fare perché ogni persona
caratterialmente è diversa ovviamente e
io sono una di quelle persone che è
molto bravo e si trova molto a suo agio
quando deve insultare qualcosa o
distruggerla fino alle proprie
fondamentali mi trovo proprio a casa mia
ma quando devo parlare bene di qualcosa
devo spiegare i motivi per il quale
questa cosa mi mi suscita determinate
emozioni o mi provoca determinati
sentimenti o difficoltà
probabilmente questo sarà un video
sconclusionato confuso pasticciato ma è
un video che aspettavo di fare da tanto
tempo e credo che sia giunto il momento
nei prossimi minuti cercherò di
spiegarvi probabilmente invano quanto
peso abbiano avuto paolo villaggio e le
sue opere nella mia vita quando andavo
all'istituto tecnico per geometri ho
incontrato uno dei miei professori di
disegno tecnico e un giorno si è messo a
spiegarci dei lavori che ha fatto lui a
torino ho fatto locale di quei locali
mila e anche qualche palazzina che
sicuramente voi avrete visto passando
per arrivare a scuola e noi tutti
incuriositi prof quale ma se quella
all'incrocio tal dei tali quella che ai
buchi quadrati sui balconi e noi ci
chiedevano buchi quadrati sul balcone
questo è ubriaco e lui giustamente ha
passato i restanti 20 minuti a
insultarci fino alla sesta generazione
in modo assolutamente giusto lui ci
criticava il fatto che camminando in
città tutti i giorni della nostra vita
24 ore su 24
noi non abbiamo mai alzato lo sguardo
alzare lo sguardo noi eravamo dei pis
che letti chissenefrega di alzare lo
sguardo
l'unica cosa che ci importava era la
figlia e lui giustamente certo ma magari
tra una donzella e uno spinello non so
cosa facciate voi giovani
provate ad alzare lo sguardo e provate a
guardare la città che voi vivete dalla
mattina alla sera
da un'altra prospettiva e 12 anni dopo
sono qui a parlare di una delle cose più
importanti e che mi hanno segnato più a
fondo di tutta la mia vita
paolo villaggio e le sue opere e come
piace tanto fare alle pagine facebook
dell'ultimo periodo
partirei con una citazione il comico non
diventa mai adulto resta sempre un
bambino è il primo ricordo di fantozzi
mi arriva proprio dall infanzia
anche se in realtà i ricordi d'infanzia
non è che siano proprio tantissime quel
periodo è un po annebbiato
mi ricordo la prima volta che mio padre
mi portò al cinema a vedere jurassic
park
ero talmente piccolo da non riuscire a
gestire l'audio potentissimo del cinema
e guardai l'intero film con le mani
sulle orecchie
un altro dei pochi ricordi ma molto
vividi sono io che sto giocando alla mia
festa di compleanno con i miei amichetti
e mentre sto sparando con quelle pistole
che sparano le palline di plastica molto
molto leggere per non farsi male
mica go addosso il ricordo di ogni
singola riunione familiare di ogni
singolo a cena di natale e compleanno
dei parenti compleanno dei cugini vari
il ricordo che durante le cene per non
lasciare il silenzio il rumore della
gente che mastica dentro i tuoi neuroni
si metteva qualcosa e per non mettere
per l'ennesima volta buona domenica si
metteva qualche video cassetta e al 99
per cento delle volte era un fantozzi
io non c'ho mai pensato ma è raro
trovare un'opera il cui creatore sia
anche il protagonista a volte capita
però per esempio con woody alinghi alle
scrive i film e molto spesso lui è stato
il protagonista dei film ha scritto
monologhi e molto spesso lui era il
protagonista del monologo ma è molto più
raro vedere un autore che inventa un
personaggio poi ci scrive dei monologhi
comici poi interpreta i monologhi comici
poi ci fa un libro su questo personaggio
poi ci fanno un film e l'attore che
interpreta il protagonista di questo
film che è il protagonista dei libri e
che è il protagonista dei monologhi e
l'autore stesso è quasi come vivere una
seconda vita tangibile e anche solo
scoprire questa banalità intacca
profondamente la mia visione delle cose
e queste sulla punta della
perché ogni volta che mi riguardo per
l'accento ventisettesima volta tutti i
film di fantozzi imparo qualcosa di
nuovo o scopro qualche particolare nuovo
una chiave di lettura nuova e questo
particolare dell'autorialità totale
delle opere di paolo villaggio gli ha
messo una curiosità pazzesca tanto che
sono andato a scavare nella sua carriera
e nella sua vita scoprire per esempio
della sua incredibile amicizia con
fabrizio de andrè mi ha scaldato il
cuore e ancora di più lo ha fatto
scoprire che paolo villaggio ha scritto
insieme a lui la canzone carlo martello
e questa cosa quando paolo aveva 30 anni
fabrizio 22
io cosa cazzo sto facendo nella mia vita
ci aveva 22 anni de andrè io a 22 anni
avevo appena scoperto i server gratuiti
di world of warcraft perché quelli
originali non me li potevo permettere e
villaggio parla tantissimo della sua
stretta amicizia con de andré anche in
ultime interviste dicendo per esempio
fingevamo di essere brave persone ma
eravamo carogne da ragazzi tormentavano
due omosessuali 1 dichiarato è l'altro
nome li prendevamo a pietrate solo per
il gusto di farlo
vedi vedi quello che fanno tutti gli
amici stretti
no va bene voglio dire dopo anni e anni
di carriera uno scivolone in
un'intervista ci sta poi la mente non è
più giovane e fresca come era un tempo
ma ha fatto anche tantissime altre
interviste dove ha dichiarato per
esempio l'omosessualità è un'anomalia
genetica per esempio si ha detto queste
cose nelle interviste ma io volevo usare
queste cose non tanto per gettare fango
sulla carriera dio sulla sua persona di
paolo villaggio ma più per aprire un
argomento un po particolare che è sempre
un po controverso quando a voi piacciono
le opere di una determinata persona ma
poi venite a scoprire che questa
determinata persona e in parte o del
tutto dipende dalla persona un
grandissimo filo di censura
cosa fate cioè la bellezza delle loro
opere per voi viene intaccata da questa
cosa qui
diminuisce aumenta un rimane stabile
l'idea perché dipende dalla personalità
di ognuno di noi secondo me cercare di
dividere magari o assorbire all'interno
quello che succede nella vita privata di
altre persone a me personalmente non
intacca quasi per nulla questa cosa non
perché non sia grave ma perché il mio
cervello dice chi se ne frega e quindi
io dico chi se ne frega
sono solo contento che hitler non abbia
scritto la canzone di marinella e a
luglio del 2017 ho scoperto della sua
morte lo scoperto come lo scopro le
morti di tutti i personaggi famosi su
twitter perché twitter ormai diventato
il necrologio del nuovo millennio e
purtroppo noi siamo una generazione un
po sfortunata per quanto riguarda le
morti perché noi siamo cresciuti con un
sacco di idoli tra virgolette della
televisione e non che pian piano sono
morti durante il corso degli anni ma non
ho mai reagito in questo modo qua
qualcosa vorrà dire
forse lì mi sono reso conto di quanto le
opere di paolo villaggio fossero
importanti per la mia vita
o forse la reazione è stato così perché
è come se avessi perso un parente
stretto
oppure ho pianto perché tirava le pietre
ai gay non lo so fatto sta che molto
spesso quando hai un personaggio
un'opera che ti segue da così tanti anni
e ti piacerebbe esprimere la sua
gratitudine a questa persona all'autore
in qualche modo o nell'altro e io non
sono mai riuscito a farlo ma nessuno
riesce mai a farlo perché sono un
pochino e raggiungibili queste persone
qua ovviamente è tra l'altro io ci sono
andato molto vicino al poter parlare e
interagire con il signor villaggio
allora c'è da dire che io ho interagito
nella mia vita con pochissimi gli
preferì i miei colleghi youtuber non
contano essendo di torino ho visto in un
negozio di dischi boosta dei subsonica
ho visto per strada tipo 150 mila volte
i linea 77 daniele luttazzi ha scritto
per ringraziarmi in privato su twitter
per un tweet che fece su di lui 50 anni
fa ho fatto dei complimenti a gianni
fantoni per un suo format su youtube e
lui mi ha risposto con delle emoticon ho
dichiarato il mio amore indiscusso ma
non corrisposto di francesca michielin e
lei mi ha risposto con un emoticon iunco
ricino mortacci nelle modi con e poi non
so se ve lo ricordate ma anni fa paolo
villaggio aprì un canale di youtube
gestito probabilmente dai figli credo
non credo che lo gestisce gestisse lui
direttamente ovviamente dove rispondeva
alle domande dei fan e ovviamente
essendo io toby fece una domanda nei
commenti che hanno subito in prima
posizione votato dalle persone e lui la
lesse nell'episodio dopo purtroppo non
mi ricordo nella domanda nel quale fu la
risposta però mi ricordo cosa disse
all'inizio della domanda per fare una
piccola battuta sul mio nome e disse la
prossima domanda ce la fa
io toby gli hobby che non è un animale e
ma è una persona vera io e io non ho
smesso di ridere anche purtroppo credi
che non ci sono più perché sono stati
cancellati già da un sacco di tempo fa e
mannaggia avrei dovuto scaricarle
piccola interruzione di servizio per
dire soltanto che sono disponibili i
biglietti per il nuovo tour del nuovo
spettacolo mio e di vincenzo vero vince
non si obodo isla o di un magnum habemus
tour fumata bianca abbiamo le date per
il nuovo tour
dai dai dai dai dai ps comunque
carbonara con la panna
no ho comprato un lettore di vinili l'ho
pagato 50 euro non giudicatemi perché vi
faccio vedere questa cosa qui per
raccontarvi un piccolissimo nè dato io
adoro ascoltare il jazz non ne sono
assolutamente un esperto però mi sto
cimentando piano piano ad impararne le
basi per poi ascoltare rob un po più
complessa e che vinili avrò mai comprato
al costo di 1 euro nei mercatini
dell'usato ha per esempio caterina
caselli
oppure dando molto sul classico frank
sinatra
a volte li mercatini dell'usato si
trovano anche così un po particolari
come walter bonatti vi fa ascoltare le
voci meravigliose della natura e adotti
passi da me è un vostro alto più di due
metri che eleva il suo grido ma
soprattutto come ho detto prima i grandi
del jazz
e chi meglio di jerry roll morton per
iniziare ad ascoltarlo e di solito non
vado neanche per autori specifici ma
aprendo proprio jazz special il grande
incontro in pagine rico ed è qui che
volevo arrivare dentro questa confezione
di vini le ho notato subito che non
c'era solo un vinile ma 21 è in jazz
speciali grandi incontri l'altro e chuck
la commedia all'italiana
probabilmente c'è stato un errore il
proprietario avrà messo due vinili nella
confezione quando li ha dati al
mercatino dell'usato se n'è dimenticato
e quelli del mercatino non hanno
controllato quindi a 3 euro presi due
sono andata a comprare jet special un
paio di mesi dopo la morte di paolo
villaggio e dentro mi ritrovo un secondo
vinile completamente a caso chiamato la
commedia all'italiana
la cui quattordicesima canzone è questa
[Musica]
io non so se voi crediate in dio nel
destino o in qualche forza che comanda
il tutto ma questa non deve essere una
coincidenza non timbrerà sai però di
cosa dovrei parlare magari dei film
magari dovrei parlare dei film è che non
mi bastano dieci ore per parlare di film
6 perché non ho mai parlato di paolo
villaggio spesso soprattutto dei suoi
film perché non ho abbastanza cultura
non sono abbastanza acculturato per
riuscire a parlare di fini paolo
villaggio
quindi come ogni mio video non è tanto
suoi particolari tecnici o sulle
recensioni specifiche ma è molto più
sull'empatia i film di fantozzi sono un
oceano di informazioni e di tipologie di
comicità e di tipologia di scrittura per
esempio c'è un sacco di comicità becera
nei film di paolo villaggio ma c'è anche
un sacco di satira è anche un sacco di
slapstick comedy infatti crescendo con
questa tipologia di film ho iniziato con
nel corso degli anni
da apprezzare anche personaggi come
buster keaton per esempio però una cosa
l'ho fatta in tutto questo periodo ho
guardato in alto
guardando tutto da un'altra prospettiva
sono finalmente riuscito a capire a
concepire una mia piccola teoria sul
come villaggio e fantozzi costruiscono
una battuta o uno sketch e siccome tutto
funziona meglio con gli esempi dovrei
farmene una maglietta tutto funziona
meglio con gli esempi incitazioni yotobi
vi faccio un esempio perché i film di
fantozzi funzionano quando sei piccolo
quando si adolescente quando sei un
adulto perché le battute contenute al
suo interno funzionano su tre livelli
diversi infantile adolescenziale e
adulta
questa è la scena in cui fantozzi scopre
che pina lo tradisce con ceco il figlio
del fornaio e come lo capisce che viene
tradito beh ovviamente come tutti sapete
alla cucina completamente tappezzata di
pane ovunque nei cassetti nel
frigorifero nel freezer sui mobili
eccetera
a questo punto venne colto da un leggero
strette come fa questo sketch a
funzionale su tre livelli diverse a
livello infantile perché quando sei
piccolo ridi di questa scena per quanto
sia sul reale il fatto che ci sia pane
ovunque a livello adolescenziale
funziona perché tu essendo adolescenze
ai delle capacità cognitive leggermente
superiori a quelle che avevi prima ti fa
ridere il fatto che lui ha la moglie che
lo tradisce con un panettiere è quindi
casa sua e piena di pane a livello
adulto ti fa ridere perché riesce a
capire esattamente cosa volesse
esprimere con questo sketch cioè che
l'uomo medio quello che rappresenta
fantozzi è un idiota anche con le prove
davanti palesi fa fatica a capire quando
la moglie lo tradisce
l'unica differenza nei film di fantozzi
con questa impostazione classica di una
battuta perché alla fine non si ride
infatti c'è questo filo nei film di
fantozzi questo filo invisibile che li
unisce tutti questo filo di tristezza di
malinconia di angoscia di depressione
che tu riesci a percepire
questa terza fase adulta nella fase in
cui riesce a capire cosa paolo villaggio
volesse dire con questo sketch cuoco è
stato un parto questo video perché voi
non avete idea del montaggio che ci sarà
dietro perché mi sono incespicato 130
mila volte perché è veramente un
discorso troppo complesso da fare in un
video youtube youtube e te stretto è
troppo stretto non si può fare questo
tipo di video queste analisi lunghissimo
voglia non ho voglia però voglio
parlarne e quindi perdonatemi se se è
stato tutto un pasticcio però ho sentito
la necessità di farlo quindi ci vediamo
in un prossimo episodio dello show
[Musica]